The following trailer is rated as 24 M spoilers for a 24 year old
movie.
This episode is sponsored by Google play with the help of brawl holla
From the man whose mere name conjures up visions of horror.
Except for that one mural screen movie he made
Comes the maestros Metta deconstruction of the horror genre.
No, there was only.
The Maestro. Second metadata to construction of the horror genre. The good one.
[Inaudible].
Return to a simpler time. When people that all have their doors unlocked,
No one had cell phones. What are you doing with a cellular telephone, sir?
True crime podcast. We're books.
There's murder was last year's hottest court case.
Somebody was going to write a book about it.
And without Twitter movie dorks had to get creative.
When it came to harassing women.
What's your favorite scary movie? I don't know. Jason's mother,
Mrs. Borys was the original killer wrong answer.
It is. When we were made today, the mask will be an enemy avatar meet Sydney.
The Virgin is Virgin, whoever Virgin and Tommy.
We can tell them on top of the cross stock.
But this sweet innocent girl is cursed with a worst social group of all
time. There's Tata eyes. I mean, Tatum,
who's more concerned with party than helping her friend.
The party night. My house are you serious?
Come on for me.
Who was dealing with way scarier stuff off camera than on Billy of
big Johnny Depp enthusiast. This screen junkies fan.
Obviously they don't watch enough movies. It's a standard horror movie stuff.
There's a formula to it. A very simple formula. This Cox,
when I say hurry, please interpret that as move your fat top of lard.
And Stu a guy who does some of the most upsetting mouse stuff in horror since
ichi the killer deal with.
Never a road.
Yeah, no. Come to think of it. Everyone at this school was a monster.
Fairness would be to rip your insides out.
They found principle Henry gutted and hung from the goalpost. That's cool.
Except the cop weirdly. He's the only cool one.
Have a good time.
Suit up with a slasher. Who's all killer, no filler.
Because while some horror icons spend their time talking trash
Or doing spooky vanishing acts,
This Ghostface Killah just bought the first mass they saw on the way to school.
He settled his costume every five and dime.
The state giving you know,
safe spaces as he stalks you all over town from the shrubbery outside of your
own house, to the ladies rooms,
to the grocery store in broad daylight,
we have a slasher on how for and busted to every fight night. First,
without a plan beyond stabby stabby, you got to respect the hustle.
Even if everyone is constantly beating the crap out of him.
[Inaudible].
So heat up some Jiffy pop and revisit the classic that's packed full of nods to
other horror movies.
What'd you call me not your friend.
And when they can't think of a nod,
they just say the name of a horror movie like out loud.
Excersice was on the town that dreaded sundown nightmare on Elm street.
So I went to the land terror train, but Howard psycho
Candyman, scary Halloween. And what movie is this from? I spit on your garage.
In this innovative slasher that rescued a genre that was groaning in bad sequels
and remakes only to eventually drown in its own sequels and remakes,
but still it not only saved horror at the time it managed to kill off the spoof
movie too. Do you like spooky movies?
You should see how we be.
Not anymore story.
I know who your mom did last summer. Never been killed. Oh,
I'll be there for you when the blood starts to pool. Oh, excuse me,
Mr. Orange and a grudge, uh, fields,
mountain Dewey.
[inaudible] ghost slice principles and Mark Walberg
talks to animals.
So you love your mother. Okay. Donkey.
Scary movie. What? That's, what they were actually going to call it.
You know, what's really the scariest part of the movie.
This cheerleader who takes a dome,
then sticks her finger in her mouth without washing her ends.
This episode is sponsored by Google play.
Get bro holla and discovered more on Google play now. Oh crap.
We forgot the comments last time. What's your favorite scary movie?
I got it bad. God had bad. God had bad.
I'm hot for teacher.